m
[Musique]
et avoue à la raffinerie de donges a
s'est classée seveso 2 je vais défi
cielo réglementation très précis en
matière de prévention des risques
industriels majeurs
bon allez les bagues check list
quand on montera je montrais que la
couverture et puis si que monta base des
ailes je mettrai une couverture sur eux
pour qu'ils se calment mais par contre
on va se battre de ce côté-là pourrait
pour pas qu'ils voient si elle tombe de
ce côté là on peut les prendre et on
voit ce facteur impérativement de ce
côté là
j'ai trop loin une approche que je
collabore moi je vois mon cobaye les
poussins en général entre le 35e et le
45e jouer et là ils ont 52 jours on est
on est on soit en tulle il s'inquiète de
voir qu'il ya des des intrus dans leur
paysage
attention il y en a deux il reste encore
des morceaux de nature vierge
extrêmement riche extrêmement
intéressant en matière de biodiversité
de part et d'autre des industries qui se
sont installées le long de l'estuaire
c'est le seul ni ont leur atlantique à
l'intérieur d'une enceinte industrielle
de ce type là effectivement ben voilà on
prend des précautions il y en a plein à
prendre pour venir le lait bayer mais
c'est toujours le même plaisir
[Musique]
non
m
à
j'aime bien rme promener disparaître
même quelquefois dans la nature et puis
faut rester disponible dès fois on voit
des choses extraordinaires des fois on
voit rien mais c'est toujours des
moments très forts
[Musique]
oh
y at il ou elle à bord rien d'agréable
depuis son plumage de celle de nouveau
bien sa petite s'apitoyer sur la tête
c'est un morceau de terre ici
la loire c'est un espèce de corps dont
un lien mais de chaque côté il ya des
zones humides très importante qui en
fait sont les réservoirs de nourriture
pour les oiseaux et d'autres animaux se
c'est plutôt de l'eau de l'eau douce
mais avec une remontée démarré assez
loin dans l'estuaire qui fait que bon il
ya de l'eau saumâtre qui pénètre dans
tous ces marais
parmi le troupeau de vaches là je viens
d hier ont garé le bus tout un groupe
qui a même une aigrette garzette de bons
appuis voilà quelque chose d'intéressant
une belle structure ça cette année
maison c'est un coup d'oeil rares en
espagne même si l'on s'est créés oiseaux
avec nous surprendre fond de cuillé
je ne
il ya un certain nombre d'oiseaux qui
sont en voie de disparition et puis il y
en a d'autres qui au contraire sont en
expansion c'est le cas de la plupart des
grands et chaussées alors est ce que
c'est le réchauffement climatique
probablement ils trouvent de la
nourriture alors que paravent ici ça ne
lui convenait pas donner un nom aux
oiseaux donner un nom à ce qu'on voit ça
leur donne une réalité
et puis ça permet de faire travailler
l'imagination parce que du coup après
sait d'où il vient
on sait où il va on sait sur mode de vie
[Musique]
à la pause et alors là on est en train
d'installer donc la base vie du camp de
baguage on va balayer tous les jours et
donc là bas avec les collègues on est en
train d'amener l'ensemble du matériel
qui va nous permettre de vivre ici à peu
près convenablement pendant deux mois
ils vont au milieu les grains à côté du
ballet fait reprendre à imposer bombe à
tout à l'heure
oh là là là là là elle est belle on
regarde regarde comme elle est belle on
marche ensemble
[Musique]
la route de niort c'est donc un milieu
extrêmement intéressant et le milieu
recherché par les oiseaux sur lesquels
on travaille on en train de coucher le
roseau pour pouvoir installer la travée
de filet ensuite le premier filet de
donges 2014 entre ces deux heures à
l'img il ya ce qu'on appelle une poche
qui permet de capturer et de garder
captifs les oiseaux alors comment ça
marche
avec le poids et la vitesse pitot
oiseaux doit ouvrir la poche est retombé
en bas jusqu'à notre arrivée pour le
récupérer et aller lui poser une bague
et voilà pour les biens vendus au bout
de la route aux nerfs face à la loire
c'est joli les scandales war malgré
qu'ils soient fortement urbanisée
industrialisés a su garder un peu
d'espacé pour la nature et les oiseaux
cet espace sauvage la la roselière
il résiste encore et toujours à
l'envahisseur savoir que la majorité des
passereaux migrent presque tous par la
france et presque tous par l'arc
atlantique français où il y a plusieurs
types de marais comme ça notamment
l'estuaire de la seine l'estuaire de la
gironde bien sur l'estuaire de la loire
et donc ces zones accueille en migration
presque la totalité des oiseaux européen
donc toute l'europe passe par chez nous
le bleu avec le bleu le rouge avec le
rouge salif use le chant des oiseaux que
l'on veut capturer donc l'ensemble des
fauvettes paludicoles donc on va
diffuser le champ en alternance qui va
nous permettre de les rassembler autour
des filets donc de les capturer
tu peux couper jus ça marche nuptiale
tous
[Musique]
c'est bizarre cette raffinerie est
malgré tout ça reste ça reste avec un
soleil couchant derrière ça reste
quelque chose d'assez magique ouais
d'insécurité exact
[Musique]
dans le soleil se lève là sur les
raisons peuvent qui sont toutes les
couleurs je prie je me rappelle est
vierge devant une langue et à la loire
quai tout cas mis à personne
[Musique]
on va aller chaque but et avec un chalut
expérimental pourquoi c'est en fonction
de la marée voilà attendait coup de
chalut à faire avant
laurent vers ça il faut finir assez tôt
ici c'est un marché qui décide
là où la lutte ce sont des les vasières
alors belle et mazères ses grandes
étendues de vase qui découvre à marée
basse et du coup qui deviennent
accessibles aux oiseaux quand ses
couverts no c'est l'équation confites
quand ces découvertes chez les oiseaux
qui en profite
a viré
on a perdu énormément de surface de base
hier et les quantités de poissons
s'amenuisant
alors on est bruyante je viens 2014 un
bar 224
alors
c'est des petits faits
pettis plesius et vise aussi une petite
folle si sous les assauts l'air au
nombre de juges binnie le poisson il est
lié à la quantité de nourriture
c'est à dire à la surface des vasières
et à densité nos petits invertébrés
qu'on va trouver dessus
[Musique]
il
ces milieux qui sont pas trop apprécié
qu'ils sont pas créés coteaux génique et
qui mérite d'être creusée qui joue un
rôle important et donc c'est important
qu'on s'occupe d'eux aussi regrouper la
chemise
vous mettez mercado on a des petits
crustacés qui sont extrêmement
intéressants parce que très très prisé
par les types aux poissons et par les
oiseaux et vous rendez compte tous les
organismes miki ando les assurances et
les plus productifs du rhône monde géant
c'est bien plus productif que je pas un
mètre au carré de forêt amazonienne
c'est soit 5 sérieux correctifs qu une
vasière
mon terrain de jeu et c'est ça c'est ça
que j'essaie de sauvegarde et de garder
en bonne qualité et en surface
suffisante pour assurer son rôle
un peu comme les déserts c'était mignon
exigeant mais qui sont assez fantastique
[Musique]
m
ouais en route
nico on va les réveiller marina el bahri
a les 2 go 4h47
juste est opérationnel avant le lever du
jour ont cherché dans l'estuaire un site
magique qu'on soupçonnait mais qu'on
avait pas trouvés et en arrivant ici en
mettant nos filets on s'est dit ah ben
voilà ça doit être ici et depuis donc
depuis 2002 on vient tous les ans
environ 60 jours par an la tête
voilà c'est un oiseau qui va fréquenter
l'estuaire de la loire en migration pour
pour se nourrir faire le plein d'énergie
avant de continuer leur voyage à une
panière à moustache magnifique mâle
petit rareté à donges
il ya une densité d'oiseaux incroyable
là vraiment sur ce site là à la
roselière de donges impressionnant parce
qu'on peut prendre jusqu'à 500 oiseaux
entre 500 et 700 oiseaux par jour et
d'un jour à l'autre c'est pas les mêmes
c'est à dire que les cinq sens qu'on
avait la veille son parti et ses 500
autres qui arrivent du nord et tous les
jours comme ça il ya un turnover énorme
c'est assez hallucinant l'observer 64 et
demi 11.5
je suis en c1 donc certains oiseaux ici
peuvent prendre 5 6 grammes de graisse
en une dizaine de jours qui va être leur
carburant de voyage donc là je vais je
vais souffler d'entre sur ses plumes
pour voir la quantité de graisse voit
que c'est un petit peu jaune
là aussi mais pas énormément la
migration c'est quelque chose
d'absolument passionnant et donc on a
encore plein de choses à découvrir et
découvrir c'est aussi mieux pouvoir
conserver ces espèces qui ont un rôle à
jouer dans la nature et font ils sont
des pièces un bain du grand puzzle de la
biodiversité donc elles ont un rôle un
rôle à jouer
[Musique]
son engagement farouche les ibis lasser
les ibis sacrés alors c'est la seule
colonie à la connaissance mais comme ils
sont persécutés ils seront tirés y
compris dans les colonies il y des
ménages en cours de saison pour
pornichet ailleurs à 5000 qui ont été
tués en l'espace de six ans sous
prétexte que c'est une espèce qui n'est
pas d'ici qui vient de l'afrique
elle a disparu d'égypte il ya quelques
mois encore quelques colonies assez
lâches dans certains pays africains
c'est pas une espèce qui est très très
abondante
on a repéré où son lit ni donc
effectivement on va aller débats liés
après les travaux l'approchent discret
pour quoi faire
[Musique]
lula
ouais
[Musique]
c'est pas facile c'est ce qui fait que
le lieu est tranquille parce que
personne ne vient là c'est assez
dangereux en fait parce que on pourrait
se noyer se prendre les pieds dans des
racines venir tout seul là c'est assez
risqué
un ibis adultes sur lui
[Musique]
vous tous les ibis qu'ils sont perchés
derrière
[Musique]
il ya une dizaine d'années
celui là il a à peu près 13 jours j'ai
fait une étude le régime alimentaire qui
a duré 14 ans est donc suffisamment de
recul pour avoir une absolue conditions
absolument définitive disons sur
l'innocuité de cette espèce sur sur
l'avifaune de loire atlantique ont la
classe comme l'une des 100 espèces
invasives les pires d'europe ce qui est
complètement aberrant on mélange la
science et la philosophie on considère
que cette espèce n'est pas d'ici donc
elle n'a pas lieu d'être
c'est une vue 2d chose qui n'est pas
très sérieuse et qui ont tous panique ne
résiste pas à une analyse scientifique
avec
il
[Musique]
laissons les races et c'est aussi un
début de voyage
alors c'est une arrivée par la loire qui
vient jeter ici en mer mais aussi un
départ et les oiseaux là qui sont ici
ils ne sont qu en escale migratoires ou
de zone c et c'est cette notion de se
balader au long cours c'est
extraordinaire c'est un c'est un joli
trait d'union c'était cet estuaire